[Music]
it could seem odd nowadays
to feel shame about one's interest in or
feelings about sex as modern enlightened
people
we're all meant to be extremely
confident well adjusted and
enthusiastic around the topic of sex
but far from it sexual shame has in
truth
never remotely gone away for many of us
because it is primarily a psychological
not some kind of political or religious
problem
our capacity to express our sexual
selves
confidently and happily our ability to
say what we want to ask for it without
embarrassment
and quickly to leave situations where
we're unfulfilled or humiliated
all these are enormous psychological
achievements
they are also generally only available
spontaneously
to those who enjoyed highly supportive
and emotionally evolved
early environments for us to be
naturally
sexually untroubled adults requires that
way back
other people who were relaxed in their
own selves will have left
us feeling acceptable to ourselves
enjoying a sense that our bodies and
their functions were natural
and fine things that we were not naughty
or sinful
for expressing curiosity about our
bodily pleasures
that it was okay to make a mess every
now and then and that it was for example
more than a good idea to be at the age
of two properly delighted by the strange
and wondrous existence
of one's own bottom sexual desire
is one of the most personal and
vulnerable things
that we are ever called upon to express
and it exposes one
to emotionally momentous degrees of
ridicule
as bullies of all kinds have always
known if you want to destroy someone
fast
shame them around their sexuality
they'll never have the self-confidence
to challenge you again
are few things more deeply us than our
longing for sexual connection
and therefore any feelings of
unworthiness any worries about
how nice we are how deserving we may be
or how legitimate it is
that we exist have a sure habit of
cropping up in the bedroom
and of destroying our ability to be
straightforward
and unconflicted sexual beings to
generalize crudely
if there's any danger of us feeling bad
about ourselves
we're going by some kind of
psychological inevitability
to feel bad about ourselves and sex
what we call sexual problems impotence
vaginismus lack of desire harmful
addictions
or a general fear of intimacy these are
first and foremost always problems of
self-hatred as a rule one can't both
hate oneself and be having a terrific
time in bed
beginning to repair the problem of
sexual shame relies on a basic
acceptance that the problem exists
and that it's probably been playing
havoc with our lives
for a long time we need to learn to name
and track the matter
to say to ourselves and then a few loved
ones i feel
debilitating shame around sex and that's
okay
for now a commitment to change is what
counts for the moment
despite all the cheery suggestions to
the contrary a lot of us
women and men are right now as in the
heyday of the spanish inquisition
walking the earth intensely ashamed of
ourselves sexually
not because what we want sexually is in
any way bad
that is willingly hurtful to somebody
else but just because
our histories have predisposed us to
feel negatively
about who we are a central effect of
sexual shame
is to silence us we get so embarrassed
we can't even speak about our
embarrassment
it's of huge importance therefore to
dare to put our feelings into words
and to seek out warm-hearted
broad-minded people
with whom we can in safety finally admit
to our inhibitions and
fears and learn to see ourselves through
more
unbiased non-judgmental and caring eyes
through the love of others we can hope
to find a way to express
what we desire and who we are with a
little less terror
it's even a massive advance to stop
imagining that sex
should be uncomplicated for us and
simply to own up to the difficulties
we're having with it
acknowledging that we can't feel about
sex what we're meant to feel
is the beginning of progress and
liberation
to take a measure of how much shame we
might be carrying within us
we might along the way ask ourselves a
few poignant questions
to which we might not have such pleasant
answers
how do you feel about your own body
how sorry do you have to feel for a
person who's having sex
with you could someone know you sexually
properly
know you and still like you
we the ashamed ones deserve to
rediscover sex
not as a zone of permanent guilt and
fear but
as an intensely fulfilling essentially
innocent
and in the profound sense fun pastime
something we truly deserve to enjoy in
the same way that despite
early intimations to the contrary we
truly deserve
to exist
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most
important and often neglected areas of
life
click now to learn more
you